[CAR HONKING}
Hello?
Oh, is this you?
- Oh yeah, come on.
- No, this is a different car.
- Did you order a "Drewber"?
Wow!
Come on in!
Wow, Drew!
Hi guys! What's up, Elba?
This is so cute.
Oh, by the way, you guys, this is Ronnie.
We have been in a car together for many, many years
and we're very close and
we're mobile roomies.
- Hello!
- Hi Ronnie
- Pleased to meet you.
Thanks for picking us up!
Any time!
Guess what? We're playing a game!
[CAR HONKING SOUNDS & MUSIC]
Idris, is there something that your parents don't know about you?
Yes, my parents don't know that I bought a car at 14 years-old
and used to drive it to school.
I drove before I had a license, too.
Me, too!
I knew I liked you.
We've got rebels alive and well in us.
As soon as I sat down, I was like [GRUNTS]
[DREW] It took someone telling me that S'Able,
- which is the sexiest name ever,
It is genius.
Oh you know, "Elba's" backwards and then, you know
"Sable" being this incredible, beautiful
rich, brown color
and we thought, you know, "wow, wouldn't it be a great name"
"for skincare!"
Ok, but let's talk about this campaign picture
Who was like, "we're going shirtless"?
- We were like,
- Sabrina
- Yeah, but the thing is, we were like, you know, it should be serious
and the second we got in there, he's like "fine" and takes his shirt off [laughs]
Also, it's skincare
So, actually like that
you're showing skin, not only is it sexy
and beautiful
and a great choice
but, it matters and it tracks.
This is another question I have.
You know, most people are really bullish on "don't go to bed angry"
but, sometimes
some time can give perspective.
We do hate going to bed angry and we try never to, but the times that we do
in the morning,
we're so snuggly, and like...
I'm a going-to-bed-angry guy.
- Oh, it's a red light!
- It's a red light!
Do you ever fart under the covers and then go like this?
- If you did that...
- I do fart under the covers
but, I just put it over her head and just hold it down
and she's like...
- I would die! I would die!
But, this morning, I woke up and she was like [fart sound[
Wait, I did?
- Yeah
I did not!
What?
Also, sleep farts don't count.
By the way, that's the cutest fart sound I've ever heard.
- You laughed!
- Really?
I blissfully said nothing.
I was dying, I wanted to laugh.
Every woman, too, wants to fart just like that
make the noise again
[FART NOISE]
That's what we want
That's better than the [LOUD FART SOUND]
I'm doing it for TV, but it was more like this [WET FART SOUND}
[ RAUCOUS LAUGHTER ]
It was not.
So a lot of people literally dream of working with their partner
What's the hardest part of it?
The hardest part is that
we are both opinionated,
we have actually quite different
approaches to some things.
Well, I think for me, the most difficult part is
coming home and there's like a thousand things that we need to talk about
but I don't want to compromise home time
because I want those hours where we have, like, dinner
and it's us and we can talk about anything but work
- Why are you not driving, though?
Because I wanted to talk to you and concentrate, but
- Ronnie
- is the best driver in the world
- also tried your skincare and it's time for Ronnie's Review
Yes, please
Give it to me straight!
Well, the toner, I loved
- it didn't seem to strip everything away from the face
- the moisturizer was awesome
- it wasn't too strong in the scent, which is perfect for me
it was, overall, wonderful
and yeah, the packaging!
That's what caught the eye
Ronnie, thank you for giving us that review
because men do not talk about skincare
routines and things that work for them
so I really appreciate it.
Is this a red light?
Okay, no.
[RECORD SCRATCH]
- Um, stop sign. But, we'll ask you a question!
Who is one actor that you would love to work with that
you haven't worked with yet?
Jim Carrey?
Idris Elba!
Oh my god! Dammit!
No, but Jim Carrey...
Jim Carrey is a classic
God, now I think I've messed up everything
We can do a take 2!
Drew, if you had one actor that you wanted to
have your next film with, who would it be?
Jim Carrey
[LAUGHS]
Well, we're here at your destination
We love you
Thank you so much for that
Don't forget to leave me a review!
[APPLAUSE]
Well, I'm so excited. They gave me a good rating, phew!
O.K.
Well, I would drive around with them any time
and you can get S'Able Labs products now
at sablelabs.co
and listen to Idris and Sabrina's
Audible podcast, "Coupledom" any time